hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and today I want to
demonstrate how to find the dorsalis
pedis and posterior tibial pulse points
and whenever you're assessing the pulse
you will be looking at a few things one
thing will be the rate how fast is it
along with the strength and you'll be
grading it on a scale zero to three with
zero being absent one plus it's week two
plus it's normal and three plus its
bounding and then you'll want to look at
the rhythm is it regular or irregular
and as you fill on the pulse you will be
feeling bilaterally to see if they're
equal now we're going to find the
posterior tibial and the dorsalis pedis
and these sites are assessed during your
head-to-toe assessment especially if
your patient might have peripheral
vascular disease or if they've had a
vascular procedure like a heart cath
where they access the femoral artery
we'll always be checking the pulses in
these lower extremities now the dorsalis
pedis want to turn the fit a little bit
this way is found here and in order to
find that what you can do is find the e
HL tendon the extensor helices longus
tendon that actually helps extend this
big toe so if you've lift your toe it
for me you can see that tendon dry in
here now just follow that tendon and
then just go a little bit to the end of
it and that will be your dorsalis pedis
then we'll find the posterior tibial and
this is found on the inside of the ankle
found between the back of the medial
malleolus which is the bony prominence
of the ankle bone and Achilles tendon so
you'll find it within this area right
here okay so that wraps up this video on
how to check the pulse points of the fee
and don't forget to check out our other
videos on how to check the other pulse
points of the body thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos